[Music]
it's fantastic products
Gregory hi I'm Bob digital
communications can be a difficult field
to break into that's why we've created
this instructional series to give you
the tools you'll need to join the
cutting edge
[Music]
now do you ever feel like your life is
irrelevant
well now you can make every single event
of your day take on new life with
twitter twitter named after the sound
that birds make twitter stands for
satellite operated portable telegraph
simply type sentences about your day
into twitter and they become fashionable
tweets on the internet you can type
anything from rummaging through boxes to
looking out the window now but you can
also use Twitter to get things that you
want out of life try tweeting things
that will alarm your loved ones type in
something like extreme pain and my left
arm then add hashtag oncoming heart
attack you'll be amazed by the results
my son and if you want a little more
attention try something like this I
think I smell smoke what's burning
there now all you have to do is wait for
your children to come to you dad hey Dad
then you win that's that sit back and
enjoy the technology experience
[Music]